[Music]
who here is a fan
of tesla who of what
nikola tesla i don't hate it oh elon
tesla
uh or i guess tesla in general i like
nikola tesla and what he stands for
yeah i don't hate it but i don't love it
wait i went yeah wait where is home i
like the car you hate people that have
type of cars no no i don't
i don't hate people you're like electric
cars no no a lot of homes do we need to
fight
no a lot of my homies have teslas but um
in terms of like for me i don't know if
i see myself in one yeah you like gas
guzzlers huh
you know man put me in a g wagon honey
oh a g wagon with that margarita
actually the dream car would be the r8
audi okay
i see you in leopard print rap cars
what color leopard print i would have go
og i wouldn't go og leopard
like purple like matte black leopard
like
dope i could see that how about
dingleberry leopard though yo
you don't even know what that is i like
her actions
all right that's tight all right so i
bring up tesla and i look to you girls
because you both drive teslas
uh elon musk has we're rich they're rich
they're rich
so rich uh elon musk has previously uh
joked for april fool's one year in 2018
he joked about releasing a
tesla oh perfect and we're the two
mexicans
a little one oh tequila tesla tequila oh
okay
oh so oh interesting oh it would have
been a tesla quito
yes it's just made by robots yeah so
bank whooped that's the same thing yeah
switches the rs for double loops
that's like a match made in heaven then
uh so
this vid this picture came on the heels
of the announcement that tesla might
have
gone bankrupt at one point in 2018
and as a joke too wait so is that the
upper most part or that was like for
real they were about to go paint
that was for real but then right
afterwards uh he posted another
thing where this was the actual april
fool's joke and i don't know why he did
it back to back this way
but this was the original idea behind
what you would call tesla kila
and what he wanted to do was get into
the game of tequila
and start selling his own brand tequila
i thought he was more of a wispy person
and cause i'm gonna drink it you're
gonna drink it
all right yeah i'm intrigued by that
it's just pure gasoline because there's
not in the cars but it's in the building
oh he saves it for the bottles
right right so this was not the final
uh end product oh okay visually all
right this is just like a mock-up he did
and
it looks you know like he printed on his
computer looks you know the the lines
are printing the print job wasn't that
great
i feel like you'll have like a zappy uh
aftertaste oh yeah there's like
electric electricity there's lightning
there's thunder on the bottle
yeah the exciting part and the reason
why i really just wanted to talk about
this is really show you guys
what the eventual bottles are going to
look like so what's happening all right
and i wanna just oh i hope it's a
thunderbolt or something
i wanna surprise everyone all at once
and
when do we look when do we look bam
[Music]
because it looks cool so what's what's
up with the lightning bolt tesla tesla
owners i'm not a fan
you're not you're not a fan i mean i
like the car i just don't know what it
stands for
i thought it stands for because it's
electric oh yeah
oh i thought i thought he was gonna like
at the oh
i don't know this lightning bolt uh
shape it's actually a trademarked it's
an iconic
uh design for tesla oh it's trademarked
if you look at like the charging station
and all that stuff that's true it's a
particular shape and style
yeah and so this is the the tesla
lightning bolts
this bottle is dope it is though yeah
that's it i kind of want to drive
turner i could imagine if you had like
10 of them next to each other they like
fit nicely
that would feel so good to just like
slap no but it doesn't yeah yeah
yeah i know i know because the toughest
high from the bottom you take them off
the holder you line them down sideways
upside down oh yeah 6969 yeah i think
that makes sense
you could probably flip i wonder how it
tastes
i don't like tequila do they describe
the flavor uh yeah they do describe the
flavor
that looks like a reposado right there
that's me the one thing i am uh upset
about is that did not they did not keep
the tesla kila name
so they're selling this as simply tesla
tequila
what do you think about the price tag
that comes with this how many months
50 dollars how big is this bottle how
big is this but it's like that
yeah how many milliliters is that a
milliliter we struggle on this side
we struggle all the time this costs two
feet 750 milliliters
that's the standard size standard size
750 milliliters you can do something for
that too right
same price 250. wow glass
glam fizz oh whiskey no you can't have
nothing i know i know we talked about
this last time
joe if you resell that how much do you
profit do you think you can make
it's 250. no i know but if you would i
already drank it though
you mean a brand new great new one ten
dollars
so you'll make ten dollars so you'll
sell it for 260. yeah
cause i'm thinking this shit's gonna go
in the thousands all right because
they're gonna like this is gonna sell
out and people are gonna resell
and it's already uh it's already you
could keep buying this it's already
sold out it's already sold out you've
given me late news i could have bought
this
you trying to smell this [ __ ] or
whatever it came sold out
apparently because like the moment now
i'm talking about tesla tequila but i'm
not talking about glenn finish
i guess what happened she wanted the
guest wanted to smell it
i know i love it he's in the middle of
telling the story you're like stop casey
stop telling
us very nice very nice give her the
bottle that does smell joe and i can't
focus
we can never focus because we're
focusing on what's important right
we're on the same break i'm sorry i'm
[ __ ] dumb we're on the wrong show
no i just i'm still i'm just happy to be
here
i love it here i love it so i love it
here so much see look
fresh water for geo knew she was sensing
that i was thirsty
you know when you first came in you said
you were like you had a drinking night
last night were you were you hung over
earlier
um hungover's a strong word uh okay
i i just didn't feel no wait did i did
it
did i bring it though did i bring the
energy no no but you were just saying
that you don't know
you brought the energy yes oh no you
brought i was thinking i drank a lot
i understand less energy too yeah that
was more regret you got the hungover and
no i understood you talking about hunk
over energy
it's the end of the day it's the end of
the day all right so i think
maybe maybe people it sold out because
uh people got emails and [ __ ] that like
sure you guys aren't on the email i am i
just don't know you don't check
i don't check my please i didn't get any
notifications i wouldn't either can you
check email on your
car that big thing yeah i've been in
like three
so many of my friends have it like
literally but and i and i
support it and i and i respect it but i
don't know it sounds like you're lying
i don't know if i can see myself driving
it you want to total it up to five he
said
matt black with shiny leopard print
[ __ ] sexy though all right
humans so it's the g wagon but g wagon
so i want g wagon and r8 eventually
i never took you as a g-wagon person
that was for sure and indirect players
make eye contact does not mean i'm
flirting no i would i didn't even make
eye hot dog back
because i knew you were flirting and it
was risky it was risky for you
okay so i think my strike my official
one strike is now cross-canceled because
of the flirts okay
i miss you um so yeah like tesla tequila
is already sold out
they've already i was like back to where
i left off uh
it's fun being on this side because then
i get to see what i look like yeah i
feel like i'm a spectator today it's a
tangent city today uh so they're sold
for 250.
they limited two per person or per car
owner i guess i don't know how they're
doing this
but well i think you don't know that
notification wait so the car owners were
able to get the
uh not a flamethrower like dude the
boring company
different entity yeah oh elon musk has a
separate company called the boring he
has a million companies
hyperloop neural links like
a flamethrower exactly what you would
think it is and he was selling that but
because flamethrowers aren't illegal
oh no fire torque yeah yoga flame that's
a molotov
mazel top malt mazel tov mazda
ymca no actually i was thinking about
the other one
a good time nine not the time tonight
i know but i wanted to change it you
wanted to do the rematch
i don't want to get demonetized for you
know
stealing the song for hitting the notes
no that's the sound you make when you
drink the tesla tequila
oh true true this isn't true so geo you
say
it's sold out you missed out on it have
no worries you can still buy it
there's a lot of scalpers on amazon
reselling this thing for
a thousand
mind spending a thousand bucks on a very
cool bottle of tickets you're pretty
sick
where you can get it so if you can
somebody send it to me oh yeah
probably would get it too wow send me
one two please
you probably would get it here's my
question would you drink it
or is it a collector's item oh right
item or
would you get two because you're rich
can somebody send it to me
one to drink no i think if you bought it
for 250 you'd drink it i think if you
got it for a thousand you might not
i would well if you if it's 250 you
might too
and then if it's limit limit two percent
per person or whatever
i totally would have gotten two i would
and drink one the other one don't touch
it
right don't touch it actually i would at
least drink a glass i wouldn't be one of
those people that's just gonna buy it
and not do
that yeah you gotta check out their dry
fruit notes and their pepper finish
that's what they call their they're
saying it's
oh and then light vanilla nose oh
[ __ ] that means i don't know vanilla
yeah wait vanilla vanilla
i think that's a typo is it noses
vanilla nose
note vanilla note right it's a typo i
think unless nose is an actual
term like when you smell it sure oh [ __ ]
yeah which one is it wait no it is when
you taste it right what the [ __ ] are you
were you a fan of shout outs to t looks
like i heard she went out of space
that's very spacious i ain't trying to
[ __ ] you man
that was one of her songs uh everybody
knows he's my number one fan
that black eyed peas use tequila
crossover that's what we need damn
remix remit
um dried fruit
give it a try do it
do the whole world that's all you're
getting consistently
what is that actual sound though like
unlocking a tesla yeah
i don't think that
[Laughter]
butterfly does
you